get a quick assessment do you think just
on first impression is Gilbert gay well
yeah okay it's impossible for me to have
the race depression because I went on
Twitter and I saw like all these things
like is he gay is he not so I already
came in thinking like okay you bought me
gay is he not but no I didn't but I did
see videos of you on Twitter that seemed
pretty gayish comedy I don't know do you
think that was a deep dirty guy being
girly is good cuz I think that's what he
is I think he curly night whoa I'd
rather take whoa no you're super lonely
where I around you I took a piece you
Gilbert I've never seen you not girly
true yeah you're very very fun boy well
you walk it's very girly well that's
just called swag oh well I don't know I
I don't think I've gotten a girly
impression from you or these are bullies
by the way not only that three hundred
pounds and now oh you're such a catch
I'm such a catch because your eyes
looked at me she's like I might leave my
husband I have a video this is the
perfect man who's who like used to be
obese and then now is a slender he'll
never cheat a guy I think they just
because they developed the personality
and character like while they were fat
like she knows I was friendzone all the
time okay I want to show you this we did
a commercial right now he's fat he
dances is that the only reason you
brought your iPod because I thought you
bringing it in and like looking oh
that's you
how'd you lose the weight oh my god you
seem super gay she's generally Filipino
good you know a lot of Filipino guys
dancey dudes but they don't burn lrc
that was a character choice before the
character
like when bobby dances I don't feel like
it's good yeah but he is alright okay go
to the question I'm hopeful but no only
thing I do on the show the voice the
voice one question and it's to you how
did you lose the weight I had the key to
well first boy motivation okay come on
ketogenic diet high fat moderate protein
no carbs so I would just eat bacon every
morning just stay
so essentially like South Beach I don't
know what that is okay
Atkins but healthier okay
[Music]